First, let's start with two key concepts, states and events. Both of
these are abstract but nevertheless useful in describing system behavior.
A state is an abstract description of a set of
system values at a given point of time. For example, it's raining outside.
This is actually some estimation or abstraction over the amount of precipitation
in the air at a given point in time. Let's imagine a slightly more complex
situation in the imaginary town of Des Cartes Iowa, that has ten streets and
eight avenues laid out in an orthogonal grid. And let's say we
were trying to imagine the state of the town that had one car in it.
The position of that car in this imaginary scenario is at third street and
fifth avenue. The number of possible states it could be in is 80, ten streets,
eight avenues. For two cars though, the number of possible states,
goes up with a square. That is, 80 times 80 or 6400 possible states.
The State Space of a system, is a set of possible states,
and its size goes up, multiplicatively, with a number of different
attributes that we're trying to capture. And the number of possibilities,
that each attribute has. This is called the state explosion problem.